[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm could be HD here
and this is the iMac pro we were waiting
for this well okay maybe maybe not this
specifically but we were waiting for a
new Apple Pro desktop we being creative
professionals that use you know Final
Cut Pro and motion or just generally Mac
os10 stuff like that but we finally got
it so this is the iMac pro in the flesh
it's probably looking pretty familiar to
anyone who's seen any iMac before
because on the outside it's almost
identical to any other 27-inch 5k iMac
if you paint everything dark grey or
space grey that used to be silver plus a
couple extra microphones and improved
front facing camera some slightly
improved speakers so minor stuff like
that but generally the main stuff the
design the stand the display the bezels
it's all the same but what makes this
iMac pro an iMac pro is all on the
inside so I've had this thing here for
about a week now which has been really
exciting obviously it's been hard to not
talk about it and not show it at all in
the background of Instagram wise and
stuff like that but it's been here been
editing videos on it working with the
new Final Cut Pro this video you're
watching this on is edited on the iMac
Pro and it's replaced the Mac Pro that's
been sitting on my desk since 2013 and
we needed that upgrade and I did say
that before their new modular full
desktop Mac Pro comes out sometime in
2018 that I would give imac pro a chance
so shout out to apple for actually
getting one here to the studio and so
this has been my experience so far so
this is a ten core iMac pro with 128
gigs of ram the sixteen gig Vega GPU and
there's a bunch of new specs as you
probably know this being somewhere in
the sweet spot I guess between number of
cores versus clock speed but here are
all the available specs the eight core
and ten core are available early but if
you're going to go for the 14 or 18 core
you'll be waiting till early next year
for it to ship and it's all these Intel
Xeon w chips and AMD Vega GPUs so all
this new workstation grade hardware like
we were expecting so with all that new
workstation grade hardware replacing the
typical consumer parts you kind of have
to
redesign the entire inside of the iMac
Pro which they did but you'll never see
it because they don't let you get inside
there is the bigger ventilation slots on
the back of the iMac Pro but the door to
get inside an upgrade any Ram even is
gone it's a completely sealed non
upgradable machine from the speck you
buy on day one so really the main way
you'd know it's an iMac Pro other than
the new Space Gray is the performance in
theory that's why people are gonna be
buying iMac Pro over a regular iMac
because it offers that workstation grade
hardware that finally upgraded inside
that can handle like if you're someone
like me who's pushing a lot of big raw
frames if you're in Final Cut Pro if you
do motion graphics if you're pushing a
lot of data around if you're doing a lot
of rendering this will all be faster on
a machine like this that can actually
handle it and I my pro is indeed faster
than a regular iMac it shows up in
synthetic benchmarks which you'd expect
given the newer hardware and it also
shows up in real-world performance
differences in render times like this
over the long term add up to a lot of
save time which is great where it
matters and workstation parts in case
you didn't know make a big difference
seriously besides just obviously the
Intel Xeon w chips a hundred and twenty
eight gigs of DDR for RAM that's
absolutely ridiculous for a normal
person but you already know premiere and
After Effects and Final Cut Pro will eat
that right up it has a PCIe SSD that's
getting the 3,000 megabytes per second
read and write speeds which is nuts
obviously the massive CPU core is
there's hyper threading 16 gigs of video
RAM on the graphics card it's clearly a
super capable machine with the ports on
the back you're getting 4 full size USB
3 ports and then four Thunderbolt 3 USB
C ports which are good to see along with
of course your SD card slot your Gigabit
Ethernet port headphone jack stuff like
that the funny thing is I think it's
really easy to just hate on the new iMac
Pro because it's very expensive and then
also not upgradeable at all what what
kind of Pro machine isn't upgradeable
and that's definitely its biggest
weakness for sure but for the hardware
inside and the actual specs are getting
it's actually a fairly priced machine I
priced out a roughly equivalent PC
obviously a lot of these parts are brand
new so you can't do it one for one but
it came out to around 50 100 bucks
and that's not accounting for the fact
that this is all-in-one it's a beautiful
5k display stealth black obviously it's
not a Mac and you would build a PC for
different reasons and you would buy an
iMac Pro but I actually don't think the
price is that insane so this guy has a
lot of things going for it that
professionals value it just sits on your
desk perfectly quietly doesn't make any
noise through the days I've had it I
like that about it it stays pretty cool
too stuffing all these workstation parts
into such a small space has to be a
thermal nightmare and of course the
Final Cut Pro workflow that I have isn't
as taxing to the limits as someone using
say After Effects or motion but even
still I'm pushing around these big 8k
raw frames and I'm able to playback high
resolution previews on the timeline
smoothly in Final Cut Pro without
dropping that many frames if any at all
with plugins and color correction
applied so this stuff that would
normally choke my Mac Pro is seeing an
improvement right off the bat I like the
all-black accessories the black keyboard
the great trackpad even the black
lightning cable that comes with it I
don't think I've seen that anywhere else
before so that's pretty cool but long
story short I really like it so far it
feels like the ideal high-end
youtuber Final Cut Pro machine the main
question will be is it worth the extra
money because it's clearly much more
expensive than a normal iMac and there
are other things to consider like will
the thermal situation hold up over time
will it stay cool will the 18 core
version be that much better than the 8
or 10 core version for certain
applications you know these are all big
questions it's gonna take a couple more
projects and some time of really putting
it through its paces for a full review
but honestly so far I'm not mad at all
also for those who I know are wondering
my iMac Pro here is sitting on top of a
12 South high rise Pro also just got
announced today it's also the stealth
black so it's pretty sweet kind of goes
with it I'll link it below and just
generally I think I can finally do
another new set up tour or like a desk
tour maybe thumbs up if you're
interested in that this this has been on
my desk for so long that my setup never
really changed for like the last five
years but it's now finally very
different also shout out to John who is
also dropping his iMac pro setup tour
this all black Suites set up to our
video today I'll link that below so if
you want to see a finished iMac pro
setup that's there but yeah thinking
about doing mine
soon in video form as I keep using this
that's pretty much it thank you for
watching talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]
you